the feminist critique of traditional
gender roles and gender ideology isn't
that some people like to stay at home
and others don't it's that you shouldn't
be bound to pursue a certain life based
on the sex that you were born into at
Birth the one issue I do have is I know
actually um someone a friend of mine
whose sister got involved in the
tradwife movement in the US basically
and she was quite young she got married
to someone who was like this is what
we're doing you're going to be a
tradwife and basically came to regret it
um she felt like she'd been controlled
like her life became very small and she
couldn't get out she couldn't Gap
because you know she'd lost all her
friends and and this has become
basically her entire life